my flowers flowers we we all have them I
have them you have them
I remember seeing a video back back
before I did YouTube and there was some
youtubers talking about their floss and
I I thought it was pretty nice I thought
it was a nice humbling settling video
that you couldn't relate to so now I'm
making it myself
original content I'm almost there guys
now where do I begin if it in case it
wasn't obvious I'm kind of awkward
really awkward it's something that I
have had to deal with more than I
thought I have whatever would because
somehow I got in this position of being
a youtuber I think anyone in traditional
media they're all extroverts they all
feel extremely comfortable in front of a
crowd or in front of other people or
strangers in general I'm just a [ __ ]
loser from Sweden who likes to play
video games I was never supposed to have
an audience and it's been so clear
throughout my journey especially being
put in situation I'm not used to you
probably know about me being awkward
you've seen we've all seen the video of
me on stage in Dreamhack
[Music]
you guys ever had those cringy moments
in your life that you just repeat in
your head over and over and over and
over and over and over and over yeah
take me neither it's great being awkward
I love it it's also something I've been
trying to work on like I've been trying
to put myself in situations that I'm not
always comfortable with and I think I
improved a lot considering like looking
back a few years I'm really proud of
myself but I feel like it's something
that I worked on I think the message
behaved for people is always all you
should embrace your flowers don't try to
change you are perfect the way you are
I'm like yeah yeah yes yes yes but at
the same time it's not illegal to work
on your flaws it's not something
terrible to do but yeah it's clear I'm
an introvert and I'm awkward physical
flaw my nose maybe it's just in my head
but it's [ __ ] huge maybe it's too big
for my face yeah I don't know what to
say about that it's just if I have a big
nose I have a big-ass nose but embrace
your flaws what is this video it's good
to be different it's good to be why I
you know what I love a be [ __ ] huge
as Cronos
be awesome I could peck at people and
[ __ ] hella dope you know that's my only
regret with this flock is that I can't
it's not even bigger that's right I'm
kind of egotistical alright at least I
can be I noticed that whenever I really
get into stuff that I really enjoy I
kind of forget about anything else
that's important are there other people
or other things that's something that I
definitely don't like about myself like
being in that position where you're like
oh [ __ ] what am i doing I need to focus
on other things and oh [ __ ] I've been
ignoring all these other people it's not
a good feeling I really wish I wouldn't
get so caught up into things that I'm
doing but it's also taking me to places
I never thought I would be because I I
really was so swept into YouTube and
it's something that I really love doing
and I think if I wasn't this kind of
personality then I definitely wouldn't
be
here so it's a double-edged sword I
guess and it's something again that I
try to work on try to remember and be
aware of these things cuz there's more
to life than just one thing I can't see
for [ __ ] I mean we're getting really is
just straw picking or whatever they
cherry picking here but I have contact
lenses on I can't see okay thanks dad
thanks for the DNA dad really appreciate
it I don't like myself with glasses
either I know my life is so hard
boohoo I just thought I mention it my
life is so hard you don't understand
okay fine skip that one skip that one my
beard doesn't connect okay I have to
[ __ ] calm it in the right way so it
[ __ ] does it right why beard how much
testosterone am I missing out on here
why can't you just connect I thought I
was supposed to be a Viking I thought
this was part of being Swedish what the
[ __ ] man well I do a lot of things
without thinking about the consequences
I can be very sloppy with things so
they're like I'll be fine
ah don't worry about it uh I'm sure I
can do this say there's not gonna be any
consequences to me doing this may have
noticed this one on me I can keep making
knots a joke no one's gonna bang care I
yeah I have a bad tendency over not
really caring about consequences I've
had it's in my whole life I'm probably
gonna have it my whole life
I don't know how to fix it okay I always
just seed this is what I want to do now
this is good to me now whatever it's in
the future doesn't matter it's a really
bad personal trait but at least you'll
have fun at least you'll have fun at
some point in your life the last one
this one is a tough one I didn't really
want to share this because it's really
like it's personal but I really like
anime and let's get real here anime is
really [ __ ] gay okay we all know what
you all you all know it anime is the
worst thing that has ever come out of
the humankind is why I voted Trump so
they could make it illegal already god
damn it I'm joking I don't know I don't
know I'm not that funny I guess as well
I always think someone else deserves to
be in my position way more than I do
like I don't get it sometimes don't get
me wrong sometimes I'm like I'm I'm the
greatest [ __ ] youtuber of all time
what do you mean of course I'm number
one but a lot of times I'm just like why
how why why the [ __ ] am I in this
position what have I done to deserve to
be here there's so many hundreds of
other youtubers that deserve to be in my
position I'm not that entertaining I'm
not that funny I'm not that attractive
I'm not that great in general I I don't
get it I don't get it man but at least
I'm thankful for it I'm really thankful
to be in this situation I hope this
video doesn't come out to mopey I'm not
trying to like paid attention like I got
it I don't care this is just my personal
thoughts that I deal with my mind and I
I just wanted to share it because I know
everyone has flaws everyone has flaws
and everyone has I think everyone has
similar ideas about himself even though
I'm awkward I try to work on it and I
think it really has helped me feel like
I've grown a lot and I'm really proud of
that like I said and even though my nose
is way too [ __ ] big it's not like a
whatever new surgery cuz I still think
I'm pretty [ __ ] hot I'm joking okay
that came out wrong I still think I look
pretty good okay it still matches my
face I'm happy with the way I look and
you know I try to watch less anime it's
something that I'm also trying to work
on really hard I also I guess the thing
is I really think it's okay to work on
your flaws I don't think there's
anything wrong with that and I think
everything is people teach you the wrong
thing about flaws like oh you should
just embrace them obviously things that
you can't change about yourself you
should 100% embrace but if there are
things and aspects about yourself
that you can improve by putting yourself
out
in situations or doing stuff that you
don't typically want to do maybe you
have a phobia maybe you're scared of
doing something the best way to get over
it is to you know deal with it maybe
this video comes out completely wrong
I can't tell and and I hope no one feels
bad from watching this say that that's
not my goal at all I don't want people
feeling bad about Phil embrace your
flush work on your floors and don't be
ashamed of having any flaws and that's
what I wanted to say with this I'm
getting an important phone call
[Music]
[Music]
alright alright squad fam remember to
stay awesome and
[Music]